so i have to ask if you've seen the
reaction to your uh ps5
tweet do you ever think twice about you
know hitting send
i wake up and go hey let's sell it
i thought my career was over once you
got to mom stage your career just went
downhill
from there i don't want to be an icon i
don't want to tell them i said legends
don't get laid
sugar and spice and oh so nice mystery
romance love christmas your new
christmas movie coming to own
a christmas for mary what draws you to a
project like this
well i've worked i've worked with that
company for a lot of movies so uh
that was and of course a fox who is a
dear friend of mine
and it was a chance to be a warm fuzzy
character i call it you know i was able
to be a mom to this young lady and uh
have a relationship on screen you know
that i didn't like before i didn't like
being a mom before you know i was sexy
and everything but
now since sister's sister on netflix i'm
back to being a mom again and it's like
well
okay are you on a scale of like
one to mariah carey where do you rank on
the holiday scale
when my uh son was uh little i was i was
mariah
every all i want for christmas is you uh
now i just want his little grandkids and
he can go somewhere they can come back
and get them
so you know maybe i'm gonna be on mariah
carey now
michael had a little accident michael
who's michael
it's nothing he's mary's grandson
he's cute i can hear it in your voice oh
he's gorgeous
your daughter in the movie you know she
goes on this expedition
and you know she kind of finds love
along the way
for everybody out there wondering is
there love in jack hey harry's life
what do you say not today
maybe tomorrow but yeah
but i'm a happy person i'm not unhappy
you know i'm happy with being me but
like i tell people i'm a career woman i
always have been and my career
sometimes takes precedence over my
personal life you know
but during coba 19 i'm a little uh
cautious
you know right right is it are you able
to date in quarantine are you on any
apps
yeah but uh you know but just one person
you know but uh
i'm just um let's just say i'm i'm like
everybody else i do what i can
i cr you know i get it in huh
has this one person captured your heart
or or at least a part of it
part of it yeah i've known him for years
yeah i don't mess with strangers
anymore what makes you excited when you
meet a potential mate
well you know i'm older now so i don't
have those and i've been married three
times but
trust loyalty with women and security
you know meaning you can take care of me
if something happens to me
not just financially but spiritually and
emotionally
i've been in charge of my life so much
you have to submit
and that's the hardest part so somebody
you're willing to
you know submit to your commitment that
that
that's the thing you got to think about
are you ready to give it all up
you know which is what women have to do
and that's my beef when we got to have
the baby have the husband have the
career have
and we do it all but sometimes you
really wish you could just take a break
from having to do all of that you know
all at once
because you're happy maybe three years
of your life where you have it all
the man the money the baby the and then
you gotta
sacrifice one or the other because of
the time commitments
do you feel like you've had well i've
done all of that i've had to
but i didn't care when i was younger i
went off and did the job and
i had a stay-at-home husband and it was
good he was grounded
so that's good but there were times when
i had a great relationship and i had to
go and do a job
and the relationship peter's away
knowing all this wisdom that you just
bestowed on me
moving forward if you do find a partner
or a mate that you do want to you know
spend your life with what are you going
to do differently how are you going to
manage everything so
you know you can really truly i don't
know absorb the most joy from all of
those things
but we definitely can't live together no
you're not interested in living with
another person ever
no no they can look right next door
or down down in their man cave you know
which is separate from the house
no i just like my alone time too because
i'm still working thank god
knock on wood and um i require that you
know that solitude sometimes just to get
myself together you know
i want to talk about something that
brings me so much joy and that is your
twitter account
your tweets have a way of setting the
internet off
in the most amazing and hilarious way
the first question is is that you
are you the one running your twitter
account not totally no i'm not gonna lie
about that but it
but it's a young man who i met when he
was 12. he was
a fan on from 227. well he was the
president of my fan club we're very
close
okay he knows me very well so i just
call him up and say guess what i'm doing
now
okay so how does the process work do you
think of something and you hit him up
and say
can you yes is it in your own words or
does he kind of help tweak the the
words yes it's my words but he he knows
the lingo better because he's younger
sometimes because
yeah and uh people don't want to admit
it but sometimes you don't you know like
somebody called me up and asked me what
wap was i went now come on now
now if i got to tell you then it's too
late
technologically he knows all the stuff
that goes with that because
it is a lingo that catches on so you
don't have to use too many words
so that so he's trained me that way so
now i know so i'll just call him up but
but so i have to ask if you've seen the
reaction to your
uh ps5 tweet which has gone up
and i'm like wait a minute now okay
only for a day okay for a day
i mean i'm just curious do you ever
think twice about you know hitting send
on on a moment like that which you know
people are gonna well that's him but he
told me what it is
so you know you get into it you go oh oh
really oh
you know so you get some you know
because i have
days where i'm feeling like i'm i'm
still 20 years ago
it's very rare you're agitated i wake up
and go
hey let's sell it
[Laughter]
is there any boundaries is there
anything that you won't tweet
uh yeah i won't tweet about my kid or
his life or his you know his personal
nothing personal about people one of
your tweets you submitted a tweet to
andy cohen when
melissa mccarthy was on and they
actually read it on air
and i have to tell you i loved her
reaction but i i couldn't help but
go back to the iconic episode of watch
what happens live you
and regina king getting a little tipsy
together
a little tipsy with a splash slash
i'm gonna sit my drink on that's right i
have
him in control
i didn't know it was live i thought it
was a live audience
when we went in i thought and i got
there i went where's all the people
i said regina we can't drink on tv she
said
so i was like hey but by the time we got
from
the studio when we finished to the the
car the service
we had each maybe 300 000 followers
that quick the twins told me that t and
tamara i said why are we on twitter i
don't want to do this
that was 1990 they said it keeps you
current and relevant
uh you know and i was like oh okay you
know i had to be talked into it can you
believe that
but when i got into i i said oh i like
this i hope you never stop because it's
the gift that keeps on giving
before i let you go i would be remiss to
sit here and not ask you
if you are interested in bringing lisa
landry
back to television yes of course i would
love to me and the twins and
and tim reid we are definitely
interested in doing a
reunion i am having a bad day
you think you're having a bad day today
i destroyed an entire church
now somebody tried to top that well my
marriage to michael's on the rocks
not even close i think i'm in love with
roger
you win definitely a reboot where they
have their
own kids i mean it makes sense yeah
cause they're they're both so vibrant
and i love them dearly we're very close
so you want to do it
in the now i don't want to turn into
something old you know
even though you can look at the tapes i
can't look at them i can't can't
i can't it's like who was that lord oh
jesus
when was the last time you watched an
episode of sister sister
i'm not watching a whole episode i can't
handle it i can't handle the truth
i've interviewed tia and i've
interviewed tamara and there seems to be
some sort of a roadblock
um i don't know a missing puzzle piece
that we can't you know fully get sister
sister
off the ground are you gonna help the
girls you know
try to figure this out yeah but they're
the leaders they they're gonna lead and
they're
they're having meetings so we'll see
keep our fingers crossed
i just want to ask you because at the
time that you were on sister sister you
were already an emmy award-winning
actress
you were a household name and you went
on to this sitcom
with two relatively unknown
uh young teenage actresses was there
ever any hesitation on your part about
taking on a role like that
just being a mother not with them i saw
them and i met them and i love them
right away so when i got to see them
again i already knew them
but we did uh we didn't do a pilot which
is what they do we did a presentation
which is shorter than a pilot
so we got closer because we thought it
was so bad
we were like this ain't going to make it
we're like no no we ain't gonna be
working this year
i mean and it took off so you never know
what was bad about it the way it looked
you looked a little unfinished you know
it's like if you i woke up and
i had no eyebrows you know what i mean
stuff like that it was a little rough
but yeah being confronted with playing a
mom for this for the first time i know
that maybe
was was a little strange for you did you
almost turn down the role
my career was over and that was put in
my head because
traditionally it was you played once you
got to mom stage your career just went
downhill
from there from being a sex
symbol which i didn't think of myself
that wasn't a sex symbol
i was just a funny woman who happened to
have some curves
but i didn't take it you know into
account that other people were looking
at me like that
so once i got to it i went oh god i'm a
mother now i'm finished
my career is over so what did you over
the scale what made you ultimately say
yes
uh when i got into the audition or the
test
which was the final stage uh tim read
and we clicked right away the chemistry
was
awesome i mean it went bam i mean i got
it right there on the spot
i can't believe this it's incredible you
are still to this day
the first and only black woman to win an
emmy for
outstanding supporting actress in a
comedy series and
as someone who has loved your work and
been a huge fan of yours for years
i'm curious do you think you get the
recognition
opportunities all of that good stuff do
you think you get what you deserve
um i don't think um i don't think of it
in terms of me
i think that black actresses in comedy
don't get what they deserve that's how i
look at it because
you're saying the only everybody thinks
oh no
it's they gotta write them they gotta
write the characters and more people can
get opportunities so they can feel it
because i'm very proud of it
so i don't feel that i'm very blessed
i'm still working
at an age when a lot of women are not
i'll probably be working until i say i
don't want to work no more i don't look
at it as i don't get what i deserve
because i'm still working you know
and a lot of people aren't you know and
people of color
you know they're not writing the sitcoms
like they used to
you know and that's the difference the
part they'll never be another one like
that so they'll have to create something
new i don't want to be an icon i don't
want to tell them i said legends don't
get laid
do you have a hollywood heartbreak
moment something you really wanted a
role you really wanted you got close but
not quite there
and what's like what's next on the
bucket list what are you still like
dying to sink your teeth into
i had a part that i i came home and wept
and it's the last time
it was a part on weeds and they picked
the girl she was fabulous and i love her
and we're friends now
and when we got in the elevator i knew
she got the part i said i know you got
it and you do great with it
and she said she never forgot that you
know it was a great part
you know i really i mean and then i saw
the billboard i was like oh no my job
but i i learned to leave the audition in
the room once you finish
leave it there and forget all about it
so i'm at a great
moment but um i would like to do a great
dramatic role
that would be my um my last thing on the
bucket list i would love to do applause
which was on broadway i would love to do
something like that or a one-woman show
something with depth be author you know
i think that's how i think of myself now
i think of myself as a grand dom
i'm gonna leave you with a little
surprise we we went deep into the et
vault
and we found that you uh you gave e.t
a tour of the sister sister set in 1993.
this is tia
and this is romero this is
[Applause]
[Music]
are you guys having fun on the show oh
yeah
and i want you to know i'll say this on
public tv this was their idea to do this
show
and they have me as their mother and tim
is their father she's the best deliverer
okay thanks man just kicking us off i
can see you girls okay bye from the top
everybody
what goes through your mind when you see
something like that my babies have grown
up that's what i think but i think oh
lord what a ham
just throw me some cheese child lord
those girls i see them all the time i
can't i work with tia on her show
family reunion i think tamara been up to
her home in napa valley
that kids they won't leave me alone
their husbands nobody
no they're great and they're great
they've turned to great young women and
um i admire them and um
i always tell i'm beyond respect i i
admire
you and i consider you there you know as
a woman they're not my babies anymore
and thank god
to take it take care of me later and
pass me my teeth you know
you